at the base $6,000 price the 2019 Mac
Pro is a terrible value packing minimal
specs like an 8 core processor 5 ATX
graphics 32 gigabytes of RAM in a measly
256 gigs of storage so the question is
why in the world would Apple sell this
computer at that price and who would pay
up to fifty three thousand dollars for
it and why but in this video we're not
only going to answer those questions but
will also tell you seven specific things
the Mac Pro offers that you can't find
anywhere else but before we get into
that and what we wish Apple did
differently we want to take a minute to
show off some of the features that make
it seriously impressive first off the
design looks very unique and it's also
very solid built out of mostly
high-strength aluminum and stainless
steel the tower is smaller than expected
yet weighs over 40 pounds on our lower
end config not only does the lattice
pattern on the front and back look
really cool and does an okay job at
grating cheese it also allows for a
massive amount of air to flow through
the case while retaining its strengths
taking the case off is shockingly easy
and the internals look really clean the
various locking mechanisms are
engineered incredibly well making it
easier and quicker to replace components
than on basically any other computer you
literally won't find a cable on the
inside because a Mac Pro doesn't use
them every single connection from
powering the fans to the graphics cards
happens with metal contact connectors
and even with that the Mac Pro scored an
impressive 9 out of 10 repair ability
score from iFixit the fans have a design
that we haven't seen on any other
machine and it led to whisper-quiet
performance even when we pushed our mac
pro to the max in our thermal
performance video it packs a beast of a
motherboard with 8 PCI Express card
slots 4 of them supporting full 16x
speeds as well as dual 10 Gigabit
Ethernet it supports up to 12
Thunderbolt 3 ports 1.5 terabytes of RAM
and not only one but two of the most
powerful graphics cards ever made the
Mac Pro is basically the lambo of
computers it's got the lambo design it's
got lambo performance it's over
engineered like a Lambo it's got a
state-of-the-art
system like a Lambo and it's also priced
like a Lambo and just like a Lambo is
obviously not meant for regular people
that need to get from point A to point B
the Mac Pro isn't meant for the average
or maybe even above average computer
user
there's a recent coffee shops don't use
consumer grade espresso machines that
you can buy for five hundred dollars
sure they can get the job done but
they're not gonna perform as well and
they're not going to be anywhere near as
reliable even a coffee stand run by a
small business is going to be using a
commercial grade espresso machine that
could cost up to $10,000 and beyond and
that's what a workstation computer like
the Mac Pro is it's a commercial grade
machine that gets things done as fast
and reliably as possible and it doesn't
come cheap
there are companies like studios that
render movies like frozen or Jumanji -
that will literally spend millions of
dollars every year just on paying their
employees alone so for any company that
can utilize the power of the Mac Pro
it's actually not expensive if buying a
high price reliable Mac Pro can help
their employees save time by running
their programs faster they will actually
save money in the long run through
higher efficiency alone now you might be
thinking why not just buy a reliable
Windows workstation instead of a ripoff
Mac Pro right well we actually made a
video where we compared the Mac Pro to
six other Windows workstation brands and
surprisingly the Mac Pro is actually a
bit cheaper in most of the comparisons
and on top of that there are seven
specific things the Mac Pro offers that
you can't get anywhere else things that
we think will sell a lot of Mac pros but
first let me give a huge shout out to
micro Center for making our Mac Pro
content possible micro Center has 25
stores nationwide with an impressive
variety of electronics from gaming VR
computer parts like processors graphics
and everything else needed to build or
upgrade a PC or Mac micro Center has
been an Apple authorized dealer since
1980 they have a dedicated Apple
Department with highly trained Apple
sales associates aside from the iPhone
Micro Center carries the full line of
Apple products and they have the largest
selection of third-party products made
for Mac in
come into a local Micro Center today and
talks in one of their Apple experts to
order the specific Mac Pro configuration
that best suits your needs check the
link in the description to find a
location near you or browse all of micro
centers Apple products back to the Mac
Pro for those people or companies who
use Mac OS based apps and need the most
performance they can get the new Mac Pro
is an answered prayer previously the
best performance they could get is an
iMac with an 18 core processor 256 gigs
of RAM in a limiting Vega 64 X graphics
card the new Mac Pro raises the bar to
what most people would call overkill
like supporting up to a massive 1.5
terabytes of RAM and up to a 28 core
processor even the Mac pros mid-range 16
core processor now outperforms the best
18 core option in the iMac Pro yes the
iMac pro is a better value at the base
price but if you spec them up the Mac
Pro actually gives you better
performance at a lower price another
thing that's exclusive to the Mac Pro is
the afterburner card which boosts video
editing performance when working with
pro res which is the industry standard
professional codec for editing video we
tested it out with our $13,000 mac pro
and during playback of a ke pro res
footage we noticed that CPU usage went
from around 70 percent down to 2 percent
meaning that the afterburner card was
taking care of the workload we also saw
improved render times in various tests
especially a ke pro res and of course
you can't get the afterburner card on
any other machine and it won't work in
an each of you either if you want to see
a detailed review of the afterburner
card use a link in the video description
below
another thing you can't get anywhere
else is incredible amounts of
expandability while also getting great
reliability with Mac OS like getting up
to 12 Thunderbolt 3 ports in duel 10
Gigabit Ethernet while still having
extra PCI Express slots left over now
some of you may disagree that Mac OS is
more reliable than Windows but last year
rescue comm a computer repair service
revealed data that shows off the number
of repair calls they received per
computer brand and Apple scored the
highest reliability school
by far and in 2015 IBM switched out
90,000 PCs to Macs and they found that
they had to call in for tech support
around two times less than when they
previously used pcs and 73% of their
employees said they wanted another Mac
when it was time to upgrade there's also
the option of building a hackintosh to
get upgrade ability and Mac OS together
but companies won't do that since it's
illegal and for small businesses like
ours hackintosh azar a pain in the
reliability department we actually used
two of them a few years ago and spent
way too much time troubleshooting
instead of working so we switched them
out for genuine Macs
another thing you can't get on any other
branded system is an incredibly silent
cooling system from our testing our
mid-range Mac Pro model was the only
computer we've ever tested that can run
both a CPU stress test and a graphic
stress test at the same time without the
fans audibly kicking up at all it's so
quiet that it almost feels unnatural and
there are people who will pay for that
we also think apples $6,000 Pro display
Tex your is going to sell a lot of Mac
Pros simply because it's a better deal
than a lot of the other professional
reference monitors out there and is
packing a much higher 6k resolution
Apple's graphics cards are the only ones
out there that have Thunderbolt 3 ports
that are required to power the pro
display XDR so even if you were to
somehow connect the display to a Windows
workstation PC it would most likely be
limited in one way or another like only
working at 4k resolution or not
supporting 10-bit color or HDR defeating
the purpose of the display and finally
AMD built the most powerful single
graphics card in the world the Vega 2
duo exclusively for the Mac Pro offering
64 gigabytes of HBM to memory and 28.4
teraflops of performance compared to the
more expensive quadrille RT x 8000 with
48 gigabytes of slower memory in 16.3
teraflops a performance technically the
Vega 2 duo has two GPUs on one card but
with infinity fabric link and apples
metal to framework they work as a single
GPU similar to a raid 0
hard drive doubling both the memory and
the bandwidth so basically if you want
this level of graphics and memory
performance you have to get a Mac and it
has to be the Mac Pro Apple sent a 3d
graphics to do lunar animations a new
Mac Pro to test out for their work and
that's actually what they use to do 3d
animation for the latest Jumanji movie
they said they love the Mac Pro because
the 32 gigs of memory in the graphics
card allowed them to get over five times
more frames per second during playback
which allowed them to review change in
preview all of their work at quote
lightening speed while avoiding the need
to create proxy textures and models and
the best part is that they weren't using
a $53,000 Mac Pro like a lot of people
are led to believe is the price of the
Mac Pro the model that they received was
actually under $20,000 so in reality if
you're working with graphics a twelve or
sixteen core with 192 gigs of ram will
honestly be enough just like what lunar
animations received and for programmers
photo editors or logic Pro users the
base 5 a DX graphics will be perfectly
fine and if you're connecting to an ass
server like we do the base 256 gigs of
storage is enough for most for example
our iMac Pro is still only using around
110 gigabytes of storage but we still
think Apple should have given us a one
terabyte SSD as standard realistically
most high-end professional
configurations will likely average
around $15,000 now that's not cheap but
far from the outcry about the $53,000
Mac Pro in a decent value compared to
other workstations the biggest
complaints we hear from PC enthusiasts
is that the Mac Pro doesn't use PCI
Express 4.0 and that the Xeon CPUs price
to performance is much worse compared to
the just release chips from AMD and we
completely agree with that now this
really isn't apples fault but Intel's
for not innovating while charging a ton
of money and while we wish Apple used
those brand new AMD processors this Mac
Pro has been in the works for multiple
years so Apple would have had to delay
the Mac Pro to switch to using AMD
processors but for the future we
seriously hope Apple will make the
switch now the low-end 6
dollar model is honestly a horrible
value unless you plan on upgrading it
yourself but there's a reason for that
price adjusting for inflation apples
high-end desktops have always started at
around three thousand dollars but this
year it starts at double the price with
specs that seem a bit underwhelming but
there's actually a sensible reason for
it let me explain the previous map pros
ran into various limitations like the
2012 model not having enough PCI Express
slots or having a power supply so weak
that it forced users to rig up external
power supplies to run multiple graphics
cards the 2013 trashcan Mac Pro also ran
into major thermal limitations not being
able to keep the graphics cards cool but
this time around Apple made sure that
every Mac Pro comes equipped to properly
sustain a maxed out system featuring a
massive 1,400 watt power supply which is
utterly over Kayla for the base model
every Mac Pro also packs a
top-of-the-line motherboard with tons of
room for upgrade ability in a cooling
system that's built to be able to
properly cool a 28 core for GPU system
while staying quiet yes the Mac Pro is
expensive but it gives you a lot of
options but now and later if you're a
small business owner who wants to get
the most value you can buy the base
model operate it yourself and save
thousands of dollars while at the same
time big corporations can configure the
Mac Pro how they want it right out of
the gate but in terms of upgrade ability
it's incredibly quick and easy like we
showed in our everything you can upgrade
on the Mac Pro video we were able to
easily add in our own m2 SSD save over
$2000 on 192 gigs of RAM add in our own
graphics cards and we even removed the
socketed CPU and found better value
options you can upgrade to a part of the
high base price is Apple trying to get a
little extra profit since they are
losing money by allowing you to upgrade
everything yourself but even then it's
not that high once you consider market
value prices for all the parts a similar
motherboard packing close to the same
features would cost two thousand dollars
alone the Mac pros custom-built an
extremely solid case as comparable to
cases priced close to $1000 in the
are still cheaper and easier to
manufacture than the Mac Pros that's
close to $3,000 already without
mentioning any of the performance or
silent cooling components and then
adding in the rest of the base parts
gives the total price up to about five
thousand dollars so the Apple tax isn't
really as bad as people think whether
you're buying a base model and upgrading
yourself or buying an already spec top
model from Apple the beauty of the Mac
Pro is that you're getting a combination
of three different things
high performance right now upgrade
ability four years down the road and
reliable Mac OS software to keep your
work running efficiently and based on
the feedback from businesses with a high
budget and workloads demanding enough to
warrant such powerful machines along
with the fact that both the Mac Pro and
XDR display are backordered between
three weeks to two months we would say
that the new Mac Pro is a big success
for Apple if you enjoy this review make
sure to check out some of our other Mac
Pro videos right over there and click
that circle above to subscribe for some
videos on the pro display FCR coming
soon once again we'd like to thank my
Crescenta for helping make this review
possible thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]